thank you
what kind of walk is that
what kind of walk is that mister
I don't know I like your outfit
looks pretty cool
hey look at that watermelon Donald
doesn't even have stripes
like this one looks like a tiger that
one has zero Stripes it's all green
it's nice here you can't even dude don't
do that come on let's go oh mama
all right today is day two of our trip
and it's our big day because it's a boat
day it's gonna be super fun so we're at
Whole Foods so we can get some
ready-made food because you know they
have like a hot food section that we
could just pack up in these little
cartons and then that way
um if you just take it straight on the
boat and the food will be ready the
other option was we're gonna get
sandwich items but we're like wait if
there's a Whole Foods in town we might
as well get ready-made food except the
ready-made food looks like this no
all right so scratch everything I said
we're getting the [__] out of here
because other than the ready-made food a
lot of whole food stuff is kind of on
the hipstery weird end yeah they got
really high Quality Meats but there's
snacks and everything it's like just
weird it's for like the Hipster person
so we're actually gonna go to Safeway
and get some regular [__] like Oscar
Meyer some craft you know some brands
that people actually heard of uh
sounds so absolute trash well because
they have all those crazy like like
whole like what are they like whole 365.
it's like oh would you like some a
pomegranate jerky I'm like who the [__]
eats pomegranate jerky dude I have a
whole aisle of [__] like that so we're
trying to get some regular food
and we got an original from
now from the beginning from the
beginning
you're so good really good that's really
good dude
good
yes finally some Brands I recognize like
Doritos like Ruffles like Coca-Cola
and Sprite
do you see Mia all the way over there
stick your little head out
oh my God it's so CUNY
not gonna lie dude these bad boys have
been a lifesaver the whole roasted
chicken
pull out both breasts I get 11 to 12
ounces of chicken breast that's still
juicy flavorful don't have to do much
seasoning and I've been able to stick on
my diet this whole trip and y'all know
how hard it is to stick on a diet when
you're not on vacation now imagine on
vacation it's extremely hard but I'm
trying to do out this bodybuilding show
too and it also gives doggies some yummy
food like every time they see me pull
off this chicken they get so excited
okay I just could have sworn I just saw
out the corner of my eye
and now they're gone
Mama guess what I got
a safety it's been a lifesaver
oh Lunchables dude you cannot go wrong
with Lunchables
you picked it huh you got a good taste
young man
so Roger ketchup that looks delicious
you know what srirachas yeah yeah but I
need to tell you something my cousin
have you ever tried that pizza
Lunchables there's a pizza Lunchable I
tried to add Dominic and Nick's house
for dinner
yeah and and after that one I ate
noodles noodles too yeah at the Arena's
house oh she got three of them oh that's
so good
on that guy yeah yeah he's too reliable
I don't know
so these pretzels have been a lifesaver
I love chips I love everything crunchy
but these guys
this brand right here if you guys are on
a diet they're actually really tasty and
taika really enjoys them and keeps
eating them look at this zero grams of
fat for one serving
so that's 11 crackers only 110 calories
and the original is already really good
I tried their um
I think everything with a tomato flavor
that's really good but this one looks
very promising too garlic parmesan only
1.5 grams
and what is this how many calories 110
calories too so this one is hella good
too but I like what I did yesterday
where I had nothing but chicken breast
so I was able to eat something extremely
yummy at night
so I think that's what I'm gonna do to
it today I'm just gonna eat just chicken
breast and then hopefully at night I can
eat like a pizza or something like that
I've been trust me I've been on
MyFitnessPal like literally all day long
looking at
um different like uh diet options like
you know Cheesecake Factory has a whole
skinny Licious and you can actually get
pasta BJ's has an enlightened section
and I found out that with Pizza Hut I
can get a personal pan pizza which is
only four slices if I keep the whole
thing
so I've just been looking at every
single chain restaurant because they
have nutrition facts to see what I can
fit so if I can just be a good boy and
eat nothing but chicken breasts I get
something delicious at night so that is
what I'm gonna try to stick to
you can always count on safe way to have
the ready-made stuff ready look at this
tamales samosas
yet
[Music]
does that fit pretty good mister
yeah
looks like it fits good oh
I hope these holes are
you hoping does it slide off it won't
slide off you got three buckles on there
dude that looks really good um so you
guys want to follow me down to the boat
yep all right sounds good
yay
you ready yeah
boat number two today
hey good job dude
let's go MIA
I'm having a Little Help from Mama there
you go it's just uh in case you guys in
case emergency you guys already have
your life jackets okay that's where the
life jackets are yep okay
stereo right here it's pretty old and uh
plays the radio perfect
this right here is your guys's boat
equipment okay oh wow so you got your
anchor right there you see that yeah you
guys planning on anchoring uh that's
when we stop right so you don't need to
Anchor when you stop yeah um but with
the anchor and say like you guys want to
hang out a certain place for a long time
yeah so that's what the anchor is used
for oh okay I'm with the anchor use one
of these before yes so you hold the talk
let go to listen okay and you always say
boat two first boat too okay okay so
right now you're gonna hold the talk
like go to listen say boat two radio
check boat two radio check over
so there's that
um that's about it for me what's gonna
happen is I'm gonna drive you guys out
okay when I get off your boat that's
when your time starts got it when you
guys come back in right where I dropped
you guys off at
You're Gonna Come Back say boat two
we're back or boat two we're ready to be
picked up and then you're gonna put your
boat neutral just hang out right there
and then someone will go out there and
drive you guys back in oh awesome okay
so do you know how to drive no
see that big thing we got one too
two that's cool huh
you know what that does
we're gonna go really really fast and
then we'll tie to the back of it
and then he'll be flying back there
you know your son's scared of speed
how fast are we going over like really
really fast
can you go really fast or just a little
bit faster
super slow okay we'll go super slow
the whole time
looking at me
you ready monkey yeah he's a little bit
nervous a little bit nervous huh even
though he's been on 20 volts ready yep
[Music]
thank you
oh that's beautiful
oh that might be Emerald Bay actually
so we made it to Emerald Bay
that's the uh little entrance right
there so it's like a nice little very
still Cove
very Scenic which is why you see a ton
of boats out here
and we found a really cool spot between
these little rocks that way the dogs can
just go and if they want to go on Shore
it'll be easy too and the water is
extremely clear you see that
so that way if you want to go between
the boat and the rocks
two cool rocks right there that could
probably swim to and climb onto
so we're gonna be hanging out here for a
while I just threw the anchor over so
that we don't Drift Away
and the dog seem to be wanting to go in
quite a bit which is CUNY it keeps
moving can Mama do it can mama get from
the boat to the Rock please help me
you're already in the water push the
boat push the boat to The Rock okay and
then you got about a good 10 seconds to
make it across oh my God
yep there you go good job good job good
job
good job
meanwhile the dogs are having the time
even though they're really good swimmers
already makes me feel so safe they have
a little life vest on so they can
technically just float forever
okay they're both spinning around
and I'm getting further away from The
Rock
so this is the bikini
mama and taika
or having a picnic on the rock over
there
we got Cooper and me in the boat
because then uh there are hikers that go
through here and we're scared that they
might scare the hikers off because
they're doing a good job of being
guarded
house I know but they're just good guard
dogs
so I need to go over there
and eat and get some food too
that means I have to get back in the
water
and then push the boat over because I
cannot jump
it's far
[Music]
you're not jumping on the boat again but
you jumped earlier and it was so awesome
it's not a big deal that's all part of
the fun
do you want to be Indiana Jones or what
it's part of fun baby baby
all right so we got a rope
we tied the Rope all the way around this
rock and now this boat ain't going
anywhere which is super cool and the
boat also has a bumpers so we're not
scared of it harming the boat and we
already got Cooper on the Rock so we're
not just having any picnic now
he is a little bit scared
yeah
helper too come on this side there you
go
good job Mia
all right so it's lunch time
yep
these guys
I'm just trying to get the chicken
breast
yeah there's a Wing
all right
into two pieces like that
and then
I can eat it's all you're gonna eat
that's one chicken breast
like this
I don't know
monkey why are you doing push-ups
you're gonna race Mama what are you guys
racing
oh you're gonna race to the log
did you know that Mama that you're gonna
be in a swim race no no no you're gonna
go all the way through the stairs
to the stairs right there
we have to swim now oh okay well you're
gonna have to swim
dude your push is really good that looks
like a tactical best
good job
it's not bad come on what just move baby
come on dude yes okay so this guy is
trying to get in the water without his
belly getting cold I don't know how
that's gonna happen ready
excuse me
are you kidding me
just get in the water you have a live
vest on look look how shallow it is
that's part of life that's part of the
fun mister
just throw his ass
you're so nice
see it's not very cold oh my God that
guy's Frozen
you see your your furthest brother
see what kind of person he is
CUNY guy
Pizza Hut time Mama got a pizza like I
got a pizza
for the Ninja Turtle pizza and I get my
baby pizza with some ham which I am not
mad at all that's a very okay let me see
I am not mad at us better that looks
like just cheese nothing yeah because I
can't put anything on there if I put
pepperoni I'm gonna go crazy I see the
fats will be insane but I saved my cars
all day for this even the root beer and
everything this is the closest I am to
be normal
very happy okay go sit down please
look at you
and the dog's gonna eat your pizza
disgusting
look they're waiting for any piece that
falls okay enjoy your food happy boy
okay bye
all right so next morning I had a
delicious Pizza Hut last night and we
forgot to close out the Vlog but today I
got some Heart to Heart vulnerable
things
um we want to share so after a lengthy
and in-depth discussion me and Mom yeah
why do you set it like it's a divorce
the hell
it ain't that serious is this real
because we never not finished what we
intend all right but this time we're
gonna cut the trip short
and the reason it's your fault it is my
fault that's kidding the reason why is
because the bodybuilding has been
actually really hard on this trip like
when we first booked this trip which is
two months ago we just thought okay cool
we're gonna end someone with the bank
CUNY family trip and then we looked at
the dates and we smashed Barbara
brigade's dates with our family dates
and we're like oh my goodness there's
bodybuilding uh prep during this Tahoe
trip most of my friends are pro
bodybuilders
laughs
like he's America
she dressed himself yeah so most of my
bodybuilding friends
most of my body looking friends they
cancel all trips right because it's
Temptation you're inspired by this but
he's when you have to live on your own
and you have to live like literally from
meal to meal
and that's what makes bodybuilding so
hard it's not just a like one or two
hour sport it's 24 7. so on this trip we
actually feel pretty disjointed even
though it's a family trip like every
morning I'm leaving at like 5 a.m to go
train then come back around like eight
come back around eight so we don't get
to wake up together we don't get to have
kidney breakfast together we don't have
those morning Bed Head talks together
then for lunch I have to go eat my own
chicken breast thing as you guys seen
and then we can't have like a fun CUNY
time all eating like Taco Bell together
then I gotta go get my steps in in the
afternoon then at dinner I'm gonna have
to like step away and do my own dinner
thing again and then at night we can't
stay up late because I'm gonna get
hungry so I have to sleep early again so
it's like a constant like 24 7 thing and
then in between all of that I'm just
hungry the whole time
and uh so it's like we're physically
together but we're not emotionally and
socially together so we're like you know
what like why drag this trip on
um we love Tahoe and every single time
we come here we learn more about us
we're gonna come back for sure like next
time we're gonna bring wetsuits during
the summer even though yeah it's it's
warm in the in the air but it's kind of
cold in the water and we felt like like
you know what let's go back to Grandma's
house can you stop you're very
distracted he's very distracting
[Laughter]
the side of the Mississippi
so what we're going to do is we're gonna
go back to Grandma's house or super
family we have a fridge we have a
kitchen if I step away the family still
feels family when I go train everyone
knows I'm going to borrow Brigade it's
just more of this insane in the same of
the routine and at least um at least
this guy can get more found because that
was like the main main main goal and so
we're gonna cut this trip short and
we're gonna head back today
are you happy with that decision yeah
that's good
so that's our plan
and uh I'm gonna head back home today
see you later
hey